[Music]
gentlemen is the final rose tonight
look the only choice she's got she's not
gonna move to a farmer those heels she's
kissed him Oh Rivertown she's a walking
venereal disease chase seeing an
overdrawn balance in your daily checking
yeah my mortgage payment tripled
I've disclosed a possibility of a rate
hike during your refi do you remember
that everyone on the ground now the
three men walked off with 1.6 million
dollars i choreographed it like a thong
a conga line right into prison they
didn't get cool semtex steel has frozen
all pension payments I'm thinking of
robbing a bank I'm thinking about buying
a Ferrari I just not have to buy the
Knicks could we pray about huh
Williamsburg savings will manage the
liquidation of the fund these banks
practically destroyed this country and
nothing ever happened to them I want to
rob the bank
let's go get our money back yeah we
pictograph what's on the pension right
that's all I'm what if we get home we
give it to charity
it's time for a practice run we'll be
right back
I don't want to stay in the car it's hot
in here hello Wow gotta get some chicken
thighs first are better than thighs
don't you think
never has anybody walked off with a
whole pork line jump into pasta well you
think I am a teen what's going on in the
world anymore look what you did to Cindy
she's looking like a Colombian drug mule
we're gonna need from facial help you
think you five-o we're practically a toe
now on you can morning heat by texting
how do you work on love buttons to touch
me
I'm groping it all over love the Urban's
reminds me at a time we went arena we
ate like kings working Priscilla
ladies and gentlemen
oh oh well you're chasing me for I'll
make it easy this is not an admission of
guilt I am just tired
[Music]
you